- Alright, great workout with Jordan
who taught me some stuff.
Now I'm gonna teach
him and you some stuff.
Ready?
- Let's do it.
(rap)
- Step one, find a place that sells stuff
under priced to internet market places.
This place.
Step two, go into the store
and find the toy section.
Where is it?
Step three, make Jordan
download the eBay app.
Amazon too but, oh there's
the toy section, I see it.
Step four, start looking
at all the random toy stuff
and look for stuff like
Star Wars or Disney
or something that people
give a shit about.
Alright, we found our first one.
50% off.
The Good Dinosaur, 99.
Five bucks, looks like there
might be a couple more in here.
Let's look it up.
(chill music)
Not a big fan of little items
but then we might have
nailed something here.
So you guys can see these
are $2.99 a pop, right,
and there's a bunch, there's
some more boxes up here
I think that has cases
of it so lotta volume.
(chill music)
If you look carefully I've
been showing you sold results,
right Jordan?
You just learned that lesson,
you see things listed,
like your yo-yos that...
These are listed are
listed all day at seven
or eight bucks a pop which
would have been great
at a $1.99 but because we
didn't fold, not as good.
We'll do books another day,
but books are gangster on Amazon.
Like an Oprah book, I'm
telling you, gangster.
Guys, it's not for everybody
cuz it really comes
down to how valuable your time is,
but for the people that
are really looking for two,
or three, or four hundred
dollars more a month,
it's just really sitting
there in so many stores,
Goodwill, garage sales, Job Lots.
("Flume" by MadReal)